hey this is presh tallwalker reminding
you to mind your decisions
a square with a side length of one has
an inscribed semi-circle along one of
its sides as shown
the blue line starts at the top left
corner of the square is tangent to the
semicircle and ends at the side of the
square
what is the length of the blue line
i saw this problem on the blog data
genetics and i highly encourage you
check out the website for many
interesting problems
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
before i get to the solution i want to
mention a related problem how to solve
the shape-shifting triangle
if you haven't seen that video give it a
watch it's a very fun problem
there's actually a key principle in that
video which i'm going to quickly go over
because it'll help us solve this problem
the key principle is that a pair of
tangents from outside a circle have
equal length
in other words in this figure a b and ac
will have the same length
how do we prove that
draw a radii to the points of tangency
both of these will be tangent so they'll
be right angles and they'll have the
same length of the radius of the circle
now connect point a to the center of the
circle and denote that distance as w
since we have right triangles we can
solve for the remaining leg
a b will be the square root of w squared
minus r squared and ac will have the
same length
therefore a b and ac have equal length
and that's what we needed to show
let's use this principle to solve the
problem in this video
we're going to construct some external
tangents to the semicircle
first consider the upper left corner of
the square
this is tangent to the semicircle and
its length is the side of the square so
its length will be one
we also have one more tangent to the
semi-circle
and this will have the same length of
one by the principle of equal tangence
now we're going to construct another set
of equal tangents
notice that this line here and this line
here
will both be external tangents to the
semicircle
therefore they'll have the same length
and we're going to denote these
distances as y
since this portion of the side of the
square has a length of y the remaining
portion of this side will be 1 minus y
because the entire side of the square is
equal to 1.
the hypotenuse of this right triangle
will be 1 plus y
so now we could solve for y because we
have a right triangle and we're going to
use the distance formula
1 squared plus the quantity 1 minus y
squared is equal to the quantity 1 plus
y squared
we simplify this and we solve that y is
equal to 0.25
we simply substitute that back in and
that gives us our value of x
which is 1.25 and that's the answer to
this problem
so that was a fun problem and to end
this video i want to paraphrase steve
jobs
you can't always see the importance of
math when you learn it you can only see
its value in hindsight
you have to trust your math teachers
work hard and it will make all the
difference in your life
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you